Let's go next to Leon from Boston via discord.
Leon, you're on the air.
Hey, David, what's up?
How are you doing?
I'm surviving, how are you doing?
Good, good.
My question is this at this point, I do realize
that we have to go through all of these lawsuits
and this health care lawsuit and everything
that Trump is doing.
But somehow I feel it's like giving him more
fuel.
We keep talking and talking about it and talking
about him and all his lawsuits and everything.
I understand we have to do it, but it's just
like he or he ever just go away, even even
when he's not president anymore.
He won't just go away.
It's just like I just said, I'm just sick
of having basically, you know, I mean, I totally
get it.
You're fatigued.
We're all fatigued from him.
I mean, we all have to understand that there's
two ways this could go and we don't really
have control over it.
One is at a certain point, Trump could leave
the White House for Thanksgiving and never
come back and then he just won't be president.
Michael Cohen said Trump might leave the White
House for Christmas and then just never return.
And then he'll go away and we might never
hear from him again.
Or he might launch a channel after Joe Biden
is president and continue to be a presence
and try to run almost like a parallel presidency
for four years.
I just have no idea.
And unfortunately, we can't control it either.
It could really go either way.
And we may be dealing with Trump's voice for
a while or he's going to run for president
in twenty, twenty four.
I mean, I know I'm going to I'm going to talk
about that on the Friday show.
I think we shouldn't even worry about that
yet.
This guy doesn't even get a hint.
We don't want you.
That's it.
Go away.
But what you have to remember, and I address
this on today's show is.
Seventy one million people voted for the guy.
And these were thin margins in four states
by which he lost.
So a ton of people do want the guy.
That's what's crazy.
I think people are just, you know, I think
it is I think it comes down to about one woman
in Florida before when he was when they asked
her if she wanted to wear masks, why she won't
wear masks, said the reason I don't wear a
mask is because I don't wear pants either.
I'll take the answer.
I won't say the actual words that she said,
but yeah, OK, I remember.
That's just crazy.
That's the kind of people you're doing and
that's the kind of people that vote for Trump.
That's true.
But but unless we get some of them to see
reason or to stay home, quite frankly, the
left won't make big progress.
And that's why I you know, I addressed the
commentary today about this.
Leon, I appreciate it.
What what part of Boston are you from?
Cambridge.
Cambridge, I guess they're not even really
Boston now.
Yeah, that's OK.
We include you guys.
I know you went to Boston, bu but thank you
for taking my call.
All right.
Thank you very much.
Wait, I went to be you know, I never went
to I taught a, b, c maybe Leon met.
He went to be you.
I'm not even sure about that.
Just a little bit of confusion to an otherwise
perfect, perfect, perfect phone call.
Let's go next to Ivy from California, Ivy
from California.
You're on the air.
David, are you doing good?
How are you done on that island?
School's all right.
Right?
So I'm kind of worried about that.
Trump might do something crazy towards the
end of his presidency.
I'd like one last thing that he can do to
feed into his ego.
Yeah, like starting a war like Iran or something
like that, I think is tensions are high right
now.
But he's unpredictable.
I hate to agree with you.
I think that that's a real concern.
I think that the other thing he could do is
just deliberately foment violence in the streets
so that when Biden takes over, things are
crazy.
And then, you know what he would do?
He would immediately say, look at how crazy
things are as Joe Biden is being inaugurated.
It's chaos in the streets, even if it's chaos
he caused.
I think that that's more likely than starting
a war, to be perfectly frank.
Experts say the optic.
OK, it looks like something weird is going
on with your connection, but I appreciate
the question.
I appreciate the call and hope to hear from
you again.